taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food hey taste
Buddies
hey Tasties
how are you doing wait a minute the
Tasties is a new name that for our fan
[ __ ] I just thought of it right now I
know when you said that I was like we
say but hey buddies which makes sense
but the Tasties is I think even a little
more fun kitschy I like it I like it I
like it it came out it just came out
organically it just like when you say I
loved you for the first time yeah you
know uh it just spilled out by the way
we're back yeah it's good to see you
everybody thinks we're mad at each other
not even close the fans are like why
haven't you guys together you're
scheduling I'm back to work you're that
you're you're going nuts with your job
and yeah yeah you know we try to do it
the best we can but it's good to see you
buddy I miss you and I miss this
gentleman right here oh I missed you Sal
it has been a bit I don't know if I've
seen you since pre-pen I don't think we
have yeah I've only seen you on the TV
yeah well it makes me feel like I've
seen you but no this is the first time
we've been together in a while today's
special guest our dear friend Tom
sharpling oh thanks for having me yes uh
Tom and I became friends via text
really got my number from you wait a
minute you guys weren't you didn't have
a relationship before I linked you not
really no we've had people the way you
speak to each other yeah it sounds like
you've been friends for 20 years we have
mutual friends no no I met Tom I said
this when Q was here I bring it out of
people I bring it out of people I can
bring the anger out of anybody and seven
minutes after I said that to q q was
going you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about I don't see the mo
Thomas man on Earth uh so Tom and I yeah
no it's a very good I didn't know that
this might have been the first time we
ever met face to face I think it is yeah
I think that's thrilling to me actually
but you got my number from Sal because I
talked [ __ ] about something on a radio
show and I kept it vague and you wanted
to know specifically
[Laughter]
sound texted me and said Tom sharpling
wants your number is that okay I said it
absolutely I knew you mostly I knew you
show obviously and then I do another
podcast called we'll see you in hell
with Pat Walsh Pat Walsh who's a
gigantic fan of yours
um and he's very jealous that you and I
have of course these shows give me Pat's
number
and the show the show we speak of
foremost that that Tom has championed
and and has a huge following with for a
10 decade more more right yeah I've been
doing for over 20 years oh 20. so I I
cut that now it's the best show yeah
absolutely you've been on and I remember
I would get reports
from you you would call these people on
Staten Island who listened to the show
or they would say like yeah he was
talking about you guys and you'd be like
was he making fun of us they'd be like
I'm not sure yeah you can't tell with
you because you know he steamrolls
Chumps is what he says yeah so no but my
friends because so many of my friends
are huge fans and I had listened I had
listened prior but I had never listened
when I heard him mentioned me and
apparently over the years because you
had mentioned us when we were just The
Tenderloins yes and I what I was told
was sharpling mentioned you today and I
said what did he say and he said Staten
Island's Premiere in Robin SketchUp The
Tenderloins and I said that sounds like
it has a little bit of a little bit of a
nice snarkiness to it which is you and
um I took over what it was and then you
mentioned a couple of times and then I
think the show began and I think Tom you
definitely correct because I don't wanna
you gotta turn but I think that you
maybe didn't
before you watch the show you had an
opinion of the show is that right oh of
course yeah like everybody that's how it
goes yeah yeah yeah and then no I was
just like and that opinion was was said
and then you you then I watch it
interesting now it's just great and I
said to everybody Point Blank the show's
great I was goofing on something I
didn't know what I was talking because
I'll also own when I sure sure I'll back
something up and I was like no the
show's legitimately funny and I'm into
it and I
rescind my previous stand I thought that
was the coolest so no right and then I
went on the show I came on with Chris
gather to go we should get there on we
should come on I'll text him later you
should um wanna we should have had him
on with you today but this is how I met
I met Tom officially through Chris
Catherine yes Chris was the liaison for
you to come to the studio I was afraid
to go actually
still in New York or Gina way it's in
New Jersey he's in yeah he's he's
coastly dies he's well all right all
right yeah he's he's not like you guys
go I have the weirdest mutual friends
with gethard I have friends that I used
to play in bands with that or in other
bands that he's had play on his show oh
right on a very very well you know him
right yeah yeah yeah very weird threads
again yeah so I was afraid to go on
because I didn't know like you know I I
you know I'm also not like attention
contentious and uh so gethard said I'll
be the I'll be your consiglier and then
I've been on many times since that and
then me and Tom have just become dear
friends the sweetest and I love them
he's not that sweet yeah I mean he
really comes at me
what is it about you give what you get
baby you get what you get don't miss two
sweetness oh my God this guy's got the
whole world fooled
on the show they Nick gave me American
sweetheart I I have a rough exterior but
when you get in there I'm like I'm like
that new uh Tom Hanks movie that's
coming out a man named Otto where she's
very angry but then I'm with you I'm
like as good as he gets I'm as good as
it gets yeah once you get in there it's
all it's all good yeah yeah but you got
to get in there okay you know what I
mean yeah the dog will get to me I'll
cry when the dog leaves you like the gum
with the gel in the middle yes it still
exist what's it called freshen up
freshen up gushers gushers was like an
adult version of gush yes where it was
meant for there it is exactly it doesn't
look very adult so what would it look it
looked like a chiclet or something like
that and then when you bit it it had
like I'm saying gel but it was the right
proper word it was upsetting and it was
oddly cold
oddly called for something that had been
sitting on I enjoyed I enjoyed freshen
up it doesn't still exist
you can purchase it well they lost some
real estate on the Shelf spaces because
I haven't seen those at a counter in
a blue moon well they might be way down
on the bottom at like you go to like CVS
like where it's yeah dust the dust every
CVS is lower candy rack has dust
everywhere I don't think anybody wants
things exploding in their mouth I know
that was the weird thing I'll tell you
what people called it
now now that you just reminded me they
called it sea gum
gum well I said c why'd you say C
because I didn't feel like saying put on
air which makes him sweet yeah putting
on his yeah as soon as this thing goes
off all I do is when you come here it's
calmness
he won't stop saying okay
here Tom I saw this over there and I
thought I'd give it to you oh this is
terrifying
says the saddest thing in the world is a
waste of talent okay you take that for
however you want sure
who signed it
right because Chris's friends are chest
problems
that's a quote from uh Bronx Tale is it
not okay yes it is also chazz's father
so amazing
now did Chris ask Jazz to France uh
chazz's merch
wow that's I think that's making you put
a chance I'm such a fan I'm such a fan
that's such weird Joe what would your
merch equivalent be what what what Joe
deroza quote would you frame and sign as
you would just say Christ
Christ was just some new tattoo there I
got two new tattoo I saw one of them and
I applaud you thank you
all right let me guess yeah five comma
six comma seven yeah okay so I'm it has
to be music based it is okay
um hip-hop no
Punk it does feel hip-hop he doesn't
yeah it's very numbers ever since
Wu-Tang I agree yeah Tom I feel like you
have a very wide music based knowledge
give us a hint folks Joe DeRosa here
telling you to come on out and see me
live because it's a hot dog of a time
I'm doing my new one-man show I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden all over the
place November 8th for the New York
Comedy Festival here in New York New
York on December 8th uh we are doing
we'll see you in hell live in St
Petersburg Florida but then on the 9th
and 10th I will be doing the one-man
show I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
uh Austin Texas January 13th and 14th uh
January 20th and 21st governors in
Levittown we are adding new dates all
the time for venue info and tickets
Please go to jodarosa info.com also Joey
roses is now open seven days a week
starting at 11 30 a.m every day
the man was too high had to expand hours
expand days come on out and see us seven
days a week 11 30 a.m every day
joeyrosesnyc.com
all right guys the Impractical Jokers
are back on the road after three years
we just announced the tour is called the
drive drive drive tour tickets are
available
impracticaljokerslive.com all cities
across the country we start off in
Pittsburgh at the PPG Paints Arena we'll
be coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island so
on and forth so forth everything's on
sale right now and then uh that starts
in February before that my only two
months left to touring are November and
December November uh 11th Knoxville
November 12th two in Atlanta Georgia one
just sold out says you want to get
tickets get it to the second show 13th
November 13th in Alabama and then we got
November 18th in Louisville and November
19th in Evansville December will be
California and Florida check it all out
right now at savocano comedy.com
everything's on sale merch is available
there for everything pick up some merch
I'll see you on the road 567
80s Punk no uh
though they were signed to a major label
you would describe them as the kings of
indie rock
I think
what era are we talking babe late 80s
early 90s
late 80s early 90s and you say they are
uh Kings of rock I would say that they
are the Godfathers and mother because
there's a hint both yes okay
I would say every indie rock band kind
of would say they're the they're they're
they're the Elvis of that really genre I
I think I think so yeah I think so late
ladies early 90s
underground it is the pictures yeah oh
the opix they were independent no they
were major but I mean you know what I
mean by that right for sure for sure
yeah like for sure so it's Pixies so
what songs what I know the Pixies I've
seen them what's five six seven
um now I wanna now I want to get the
song is it a song that you would
consider was oh it's a very it's
arguably their most popular song
arguably
uh uh Here Comes Your Man no that I
guess that's their most popular song
well that's right Same album It's isn't
it uh uh well the most popular one is
the one from
Fight Club is a hey that's what wears my
mind yeah where's my mind
um uh
what's the one with the
it's been I gotta I gotta look at a
setlist because there's one that they
there's a lyric on one of them they're
always sing all the time that had to it
was a lyric I didn't like uh but I loved
the song I mean literally
I haven't thought I haven't I just I'm
just blanking let me just to tell you
yeah
it's from this monkey's gone sure
yeah sure like you had it yes it yeah
okay is it this monkey's gone to heaven
this monkey
if man is fine okay the devil is six and
God is seven okay five six seven okay
it's kind of a cool-eyed thing to me
like yeah it's not a reminder of of the
of the these Earthly trappings yeah I
probably wouldn't have remembered that
lyric I love that you don't remember it
but I know the song it would suck if
you'd be like oh dude everybody's got it
yeah yeah well maybe everybody does I
don't know okay you need a tattoo to
remind you of these Earthly trappings
like if I said at the right minute of
every day I'm reminded of how it is I
like it it's I'm saying it yes yes I'm
saying it the wrong way I'm very uh I'm
very uh stuck right now on on teaching
myself significant and Powerless I am in
all of this and that's something that is
very relevant to that even though I'm
not religious I don't believe in God
necessarily or anything like that but I
do like the idea that man is the is the
low part of the totem pole the universe
and everything else is much better sure
anyways I'm with you yeah yeah see and
then you got a Keith Robinson stinks
yeah
you get these were these sober tattoos
that's sober I have not drank in weeks
because of this this this health regimen
that I'm on I was dead sober I got these
both at skank Fest um
back to back yeah oh
um yeah
uh did they hold it at a prison this
year to cut out the middle man
music did a whole lot of prison a lot
cut out the middle man
Tom texted us that joke not once but
twice so the same thread two weeks apart
the fact that you forgot that you had
said it means to me that you are writing
these clips down before texting them oh
no I just I forget what I thought of
already my brain is starting to go now I
can barely hold on to these things they
seem new sometimes and they're old you
ever on stage and do that oh oh yeah
yeah like a bunch of sets in a night and
you go to say joking like they're just
staring at you like did I just say that
at the top of this oh [ __ ] I'm not above
that I'm not I ask uh yeah
one time I did I was like it's my sixth
spot guys but um were those um thoughts
on the fly or did you have those in the
chamber like one day I might get these
no I haven't documented a note in my
phone of like potential idea that I want
I put it in there and if it lasts
question there I'm like okay I know I
really want it so both of these were in
there Believe It or Not Keith Robinson
snakes has been on my phone
for years and I I was sitting at skank
Fest getting this done
and I was talked Godfrey came in and I
was talking to him while I was getting
it done and somehow that came up and I
was like wait dude why do I not get that
right now he was like no you should you
shouldn't I was like I go I'm gonna get
it right now I saw the video but what
did Keith like you know what a cute
thing he was he thought it was funny but
obviously I think he was touched
because he knows it's out of love right
of course you need to admit it yeah
Marina put it Marina had the best
reaction she goes she goes Joe that's
very sweet and I was like it is done uh
way more out of love it means I love
Keith Robinson yeah yeah yeah but it's
my favorite tattoo so when are you gonna
get your Joe DeRosa stinks oh um
sleep on that one but um put it in the
notes anybody who says to you yeah you
should you should you realize you're the
one getting the tattoo the easiest thing
in the world is to encourage someone to
get a tattoo you're not putting your
tattoo down I'm saying like that is not
actual impression somebody goes yeah do
it oh yeah I agree it wasn't him saying
that that made me go oh this is a great
idea it was already on my phone and I
was like why am I not doing that right
now and he was you just they're getting
excited I was like wait yeah I could
just do it right now what's your most
regrettable tattoo do you have any time
I covered it and that's that's a choice
obviously yeah you don't seem like a
tattoo has it escaped you or are you
just like not for me I just never could
think of something that I would want to
keep seeing I think I get it's so
disinterested in so many things I'd be
just like why did I get this yeah it
happens too I don't like minions anymore
it's like going back and looking at it
it's like going back and looking at a
joke that you told like 20 is gonna be
like I just like that joke that joke
I look it's like I I have a tattoo on me
that I got
uh Jesus now 20 24 years ago whatever it
was it's my first tattoo and it's my
most regrettable wait what is it but
it's not regrettable because my dad took
me
and um it was my first tattoo and it
reminds me of that moment and my dad had
recently turned like was about to turn
50 he was going to like a midlife thing
and he got his first tattoo and then
after that he took me to get mine when I
turned 18. you got on your ankle it's
bad like a [ __ ] Girardi girl
really well let me just say this okay
you've showed me this and I forget what
it is let me let me just say this when I
got it in uh I guess it was a 19 I was
it was 1994 or something I I was like uh
you know I was there was a grunge I was
like a hippie I had long hair I I I I
you know I was like um you know that was
the style back then Blind Melon tattoo
no thank God I was gonna say it's worse
that would be my favorite no it's no
band or anything so this is what
happened I went and I remember this
before but I go with my dad and so it's
special like it was illegal in New York
we had to go to Jersey yeah and we get
there and I looked through the whole
place I didn't think like I could get my
own thing I was like let me go look
through the books I didn't really I love
look through everything and I couldn't
find anything and I want to say this
back then I don't I think this has
changed but back then there was a real
arrogance with tattoo uh tattoo artists
and tattoo shop owners they at least
here and in Jersey they would treat you
like you're wasting my time like what do
you want let's go let's go like I'm the
professional you're lucky to that's how
it always felt so I was young I was a
little intimidated I went there I
couldn't find anything I liked
and then my dad's like really you're not
gonna get anything like this out of all
this and I was like yeah and thank God I
didn't get thank God but actually thank
God the guy was a dick right well he he
really only made me get a worse another
different tattoo that's just as bad but
I said at the time I really I love
cartoons
but I go uh or I guess maybe uh I felt
forced and I just was like maybe the
Daffy Duck okay well all right Daffy
Duck yeah and then the guy goes I swear
to you I don't know who treats a human
like this let alone a customer he goes
yeah he goes you look like a cartooner
when you came in a cartoon a cartooner
oh my God that's how they talking Roger
Rabbit yeah
I was like I felt so stupid I was about
to be like let me have you know
skull killing the snake you know I don't
know and then he goes well this is new
and he gives me one last book and I open
it and this tribal stuff in it now this
is before it was co-opted by the guido
community and anything like that
this is when it was still underground
instead sure I know never mind never
gonna I don't like tribal stuff
shouldn't be on me like back then I'm
18. I didn't know I'm like oh this is
really cool abstract designs and so I
was like I'll put a little band of
tribal around my ankle this is before
anyone it was a before it was a fad
before it was taken over by a certain
and you know before it was corny it was
just fresh and I did it and in the
moment everyone loved it everyone's like
ah cool you got a gathering around now I
know how bad it is I mean it's just
terrible it's just really really a bad
tattoo oh my God it's it's hard that
looks like it took a while too it why it
looks like it took a while I don't
remember it hurt though it hurt really
bad why don't you get it covered
like you did what do you mean don't you
have a solid black well I have solid
black there to cover up my most
regrettable tattoo but I and I had it
turned into something but I thought you
had a solid black band no but a lot of
people do to cover up stuff like that
but my point is a solid black band
around your ankle I think would look
kind of cool you know
I don't it'll be better than this but
here's how I feel this has been part of
my
identity and image since I'm 18. I went
with my dad it's a Memory I almost feel
like the better or worse I keep it on my
body and that's what that was you know I
mean I have two Jaden Smith's on my
thighs I'm not gonna get rid of those
you know what I mean yeah no I hear you
I hear you Kyle Kinane is big into that
like you have to celebrate your bad
tattoos but his bad tattoos are like
kind of like still kind of funny and
kitschy yeah so I always combated him on
that stage right I'm like no there's
like a worse version of what you're
talking about so to just to cap the
story sometime later not that long after
I used to work in a delicatessen a
24-hour Deli here okay and I was at the
register ringing people up and a big
like a year later not even a big a big
tank top tan Guido dude comes in right
and the height The Identical I'm not
being 100 identical tattoo is around his
bicep and I go
oh I'm ringing off I go oh my God I have
that tattoo and he goes no you don't and
I said no I have that tattoo he goes
it's impossible I paid money to have it
drawn for me specifically they can't
sell it I said well I said do you want
to believe that or do you want me to
show you and then you take it up with
the guys right and he's like where and I
just pointed down to my ankle and he
went that [ __ ] that guy think
his name was Doug he's like where did I
[ __ ] go back there I paid for this to
be an original wow so there you go yeah
don't you love that period too we're
tribal anything that looked like Thorns
meant tribal like what tribe you know
what I mean like what like I remember
calling stuff like that tribal barbed
wire but no this is this one seems you
were you were riding your bike on
Highland Boulevard
what tribe were you I had my tribe but
yeah we had a gang a bike a bicyclists
but I mean based on why was it called
tribal like what I guess the aesthetic
of it like that's what I mean though
like what is like tribal to me looks
nothing like that like I don't not stand
behind this right neither in Concepts in
theory or on my body oh God Ed Hardy
started it you don't want to hear that
oh God in the 70s yeah oh well this is I
mean this is 94. this is
I don't I don't know I think tribal I
think of like almost like Asian
lettering that sort of aesthetic like
that like what what what tribe around
the world has that as their yeah I'm
saying yeah the one on the left sort of
but not the it's it's so it's so
horrible now like in the summer that tat
is out the whole time and uh I know I'm
mocked roundly and snickered at but I
own it and it's on the ankle I know when
you die
and you're on the slab yeah and someone
goes in and takes a picture and puts it
on the internet yeah those tattoos will
tell the story
you just you just had my worst fear I
swear to God you said my worst fear
because there's no human being that has
that job that is not going to stop
photographing a man with Jaden Smith
tattoos on his thighs so I'm my my body
is going to be on the internet one day
dead I think it is and it's my worst
feeling I think about all the time and
you just said that he's gonna say you
know the guy at the morgue is gonna say
get in here you got to see this
[Laughter]
do you mean
[Laughter]
oh my God man yeah I'm scared I was I
was getting a massage once on the up and
up and uh at the end of it the woman
leaned in she she was an Asian woman but
it was at it wasn't like anything you
know bad it was a professional place and
she leaned in it was like the 57th
minute and I was on my back and she
leaned in and right she was right here I
heard her whisper right she goes
for 57 minutes and I just turned around
I had to do I turned around and looked
and I went no
because that would be ridiculous
it's his son
it's his child and I put my head back in
the thing and started laughing she's
like he has a 15 year old boy inside
the left Jaden is 15 the right's 21.
yeah how was he now he's like 30 now
right not even close stuff not even
close to that yeah 23 yeah that's it uh
maybe you know what he was 21 when I
filmed the movie in 2008 so he's
probably 25. okay so 15. yeah 15 16 and
how old's the second time he's 20 is 21
he's 21 so we're talking about every six
years every six right it's gonna be just
the tradition two years don't you you're
saying that this has been brought up
yeah this has been brought up on the
show and they they marked the difference
in time and they want me to get a third
one on that and honestly I'll tell you
right now this was a hard sell because
they threw it on me in the movie he
he Springs it on me and then we go to a
tattoo shop and he poses for it yeah and
and I was like you know do I want
another one of these things it's five
hours long it's another boy on my leg
I'm like what do I do
my lady doesn't like him you know and I
was like but I have to do it in the name
of Comedy I have to do it it's this is
set up is undeniable I have to do it so
I got it and I don't know if it's
because the show plays all the time
people are very very well aware of this
one a lot of people saw the movie but
I've said this before happened in 2018
the movie came out in 2019. no one has
ever ever ever ever once mentioned the
other one to me they never brought it up
they never said anything that never once
only the first one yeah the movie came
out in 2020. oh 2020 right it was the
last thing I saw that's right it was in
the theater and I was like should I be
in a theater I might be getting riding
right it was right at the break of of
the virus we were in our we were heading
into our fifth week in theaters when it
came out but we will forever be the one
of the 10 movies that were in theaters
when the world shut yeah do you ever
make eye contact with them during sex
well no you're not looking down I mean
the logistics are rough I forget I have
them
I I forget temporarily forget and I'll
go go to get in the shower and I'll look
in the mirror and be like come on you
know
and who you got to get to do the next
one Doug
you gotta go to jail
where I graduated too it'll be like I
knew you were a Jaden Smith or the
second you walked in here the idea is do
I get another chain and they say get him
every stage of his life until late or
just get like you know Willow Jada and
will and then have like a Mount
Rushmore sure yeah mount smithmore stick
to Jade just Jaden right yeah yeah
should I continue to get him on my own
just because
no you wouldn't see you just did what he
did you just did what he said you're
he's like I would you said it like I'd
be foolish not to I would 100 do it I
was gonna say two minutes ago but you
kept talking
you see this no every day of my entire
life go with the new thought instead of
my thoughts sorry Jesus every day of my
entire life
ADHD
it's not it's no I'm medically medically
diagnosed I'm on medication and I called
you out so stop with your thought stop
continue back to it I was gonna say two
minutes ago if I were you with or
without the show I would continue to get
it every six years which is what I asked
and you think that's a good idea I'm
saying I was going to say it before
right because you thought you thought
that my saying you should do it was
disingenuine disingenuous right no all
I'm saying is it's very easy for you to
say that but I still wonder if it's a
good idea look at me yeah that's true
I'm getting stuff coming from him it's
true yeah yeah
sorry about the introduction on the
spill all right go ahead wait wait what
go back to the shirt now and just
spilled a little water on it sure Oh I
thought you were saying no I spilled my
water and you know this I think you know
this I think it's odd that you think
it's a phenomenon that you spill water
on yourself every day you're sloppy
Thomas every day but it's because you're
not careful that's all well what did I
do there I just raised that to my mouth
you were interrupting me because I'm
thinking about what you wanted to say
chances are you weren't focused on the
glass no I wasn't interviewing you I was
drinking as you spoke about hd8d
I just was taking a step listening to
you and it spilled and I was like so is
the spill coming from from before it
hits your mouth or it's coming out off
your lip if my lip okay and so I noticed
this happening to me like a few years
ago like five years slow it down a
little bit I understand that's what I
was saying but I wasn't in a hurry
though here's the thing it happens every
day and this is why I brought it up
because I think it's crazy because it
happens
every day it does not not happen I can't
remember which I think is a light curse
I can't remember a meal I can't remember
a meal that I've had with my mom where
at some point with the mom with Dory my
mom goes oh [ __ ] because she dripped
something on herself well me and her got
a light hacked it's not a curse it's
because she's I watch what she does and
she's not careful but but can I ask you
this if it happened to you two two three
four days in early like this is crazy a
couple of weeks see a doctor yeah
there's some neurological issues
I don't think some synapse is not
connecting I swear to God it has but now
it has happened to me for years straight
and I've already gotten I've already had
a phase where I was like does anybody
does anyone else believe this now I just
it drops and it's inside I go I can't
believe this
if you keep spilling water it's a sign
of good luck
yeah no [ __ ] the kids got good luck
[ __ ] buying a mansion
throwing [ __ ] milk in people's faces
I didn't leave that to [ __ ] tell me
and you're buying a house in the Poconos
tomorrow
what an [ __ ]
he's doing the same thing
all right sorry go ahead Tom yeah wait
wait wait wait wait oh yeah what oh I
thought you're gonna read this me yeah
it's about luck oh I don't know it says
spilled water also means there could be
a spirit in your home
[Laughter]
any encounters ever do you believe in
them
um no real encounters I don't think I'd
have to see something to truly believe
yeah I'm not gonna say it doesn't exist
or it does I don't know show me I need
your spirit political time to show up oh
spirit this water spirit that yes makes
you spill every day
appear
I didn't believe until we just saw a
video with a ghost on it from someone I
knew yesterday a trap lies ahead of you
It is believed that whenever you spill
water and fall
while walking on the wet floor surface
it is a message to make you cautious I'm
sorry I don't have my glasses this is a
sign that someone has set up
set a trap ahead of you and you
anyone anyone you you pre-about you are
about to become a victim of the shop
therefore you need to be very Vigilant
this is very ambiguous I don't one way
to prevent this from happening is by not
trusting the people around you what what
is this a spirit is trying to get your
attention is one of the things you're
losing control of your emotion emotions
I didn't need all this I forgot attached
to the spill I was already neurotic
about it that I had a light hex on me
I'm just trying to help you yeah now I
think there's just Spirits swirling
about it I need to shout out to Stefano
the pig for uh
he sent me the funniest text I laughed
for 20 minutes folks the warm weather is
here
Miracle brand
to help you
eating sweat off you
I hate the hot sleepless nights I can't
stand it I run hot all the time and I
recently found that a great way to stay
cool at night uh and and prevent me
waking up all sweaty and sticky was
Miracle Brands self-cooling bed sheets
they help you stay comfortable all night
long did you know that your temperature
at night can have one of the greatest
impacts on your Sleep Quality if you
wake up too hot or too cold even that's
the other direction with this uh I
highly recommend that you check out
Miracle Brands self cooling bed sheets
all right inspired by silver infused
Fabrics made by NASA
Miracle brand makes temperature
regulating bedding so you can sleep at
the perfect temperature all night long
you got NASA in your bedroom folks not
many of us have been able to say that
since we used to hang out at bars near
the air base in the 60s that's a little
joke people it's a little NASA humor
anyway NASA's coming to your home
through Miracle brand
self cooling properties okay
self-cleaning properties these sheets
are infused with natural silver that
prevent 99.9 of bacterial growth leaving
them to stay cleaner and fresh three
times longer than other sheets which is
awesome
could you hate anything more than having
to do a load of laundry oh my gosh and
also they're better for your skin I have
sensitive skin I love when sheets are
better for your skin uh when anything's
better for your skin but sheets really
can can be a problem if you have
sensitive skin because you end up
sleeping on bacteria and stuff clean
sheets make less bacteria to clog your
pores Miracle brand is helping with that
so uh we've got a special deal for for
our listeners you use the promo code
taste buds and at at checkout and you're
going to save 40 percent
and you get three free Tales
Miracles so confident in their product
it's back with a 30-day money-back
guarantee
if you're not 100 satisfied you'll get a
full refund upgrade your sleep with
Miracle brand go to try miracle.com
tastebuds and use promo code taste buds
at checkout use the code taste buds at
checkout to claim your free three-piece
towel set and save 40 off again thank
you Miracle brand for sponsoring this
episode go to try miracle.com
tastebuds and use promo code tastebuds
at checkout
go to trimirical.com
tastebuds and use promo code taste buds
at checkout
Roe
row Rowan is here to get rid of a couple
things for you and and add a few things
first of all they're here to get rid of
the Pains of a dress shirt nobody likes
no no not nobody but a lot of people
don't like a dress shirt they're
uncomfortable they're tight it's never
the right size I always have that
problem uh Rowan's here to help get rid
of the hassle changing clothes for
different activities you go to work
you're wearing one thing you go out
after you want to change you go to the
dance then you got to change then you go
to the park you go to your frisbee game
whatever it is you always got to change
anyway and roan is also here to help you
feel great about looking good all the
time without having to go through all
the nonsense so
the dress shirt was due for a radical
reinvention and Rhone stepped up to the
plate with rhone's commuter shirt it's
the most comfortable breathable and
flexible shirt shirt known to man
here's why
it allows for Mobility okay it's a
comfortable four-way stretch fabric
providing breathability and flexibility
that leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws at you
uh on your commute to work or maybe it's
your 18 holes of golf or it's both
roane's going to help you look good in
an easy way it's time to feel confident
with a wrinkle free shirt without the
hassle I love the wrinkle free aspect
the wrinkle release technology wrinkles
disappear allows wrinkles to disappear
as you stretch and wear the T-shirt the
wrinkle free technology allows the
wrinkles to disappear as you stretch and
wear the shirt throughout the day it's
that easy and it's odor free Tech called
gold Fusion which is anti-odor
technology it's got you smelling fresh
and clean all day long road is 100
machine washable so you can ditch the
dry cleaning all together I like growing
I like what they're doing I like a
flexible shirt I like to look where I
have the option to look casual and and
still presentable or dressed at the same
time I think there aren't enough
clothing brands that are allowing for
that and I think Rhone is a great brand
especially when you're trying trying to
do that with also just flexing maybe a
bit of style for yourself the commuter
shirt can get you through any work day
and straight into whatever comes
afterwards so go to Rhone that's r h o n
e.com slash taste buds and use promo
code taste buds you're going to save 20
off your entire order
again save 20 off your entire order when
you head to
rhone.com taste buds and use the promo
code
promo code promo code taste buds all
right it's time to find your corner
offer office
and use the promo code taste buds it's
time to find your corner office Comfort
at this time okay it's about taste buds
it was when I was getting the results of
my health stuff back and I was like look
I got to make some changes one thing is
I go you know
I got to get my stress levels down and
and Chris wrote back he goes oh my God
you're gonna drop dead yelling at
Skittles with a man who's afraid of
pointy pillows you are sworn
I'm afraid of pointy pills dude points
points it made me laugh or I'm dead
serious for 20 [ __ ] minutes I was
like cackling my house I'll tell you
what else what else has been making you
laugh the fact that Tom yes loves the
filet of fish yes
yes which brings us we're here to talk
which brings us to what we're here for
today Tom has come cross country to just
for this just for this yes I'm going
right back to the airport yeah Hey
Thomas come from the airport and has
caught waiting to go to the airport he
loves to filet-o fish so much he wanted
to drop in and defend it to the death
this is today's episode which is filet
of fish yay or nay or the way we worded
it was filet or fish oh yeah or kill me
yes Joe you hate the filet of fish I
hate to fillet fish my love at
McDonald's is no secret on this program
we've talked about it obviously very
normal I know I like to once I like
program break out a little class okay uh
we you know obviously we don't need to
get into my love of McDonald's by the
way Happy Meal adult toys some of them
are selling for three hundred thousand
dollars on eBay and I didn't go and get
one of these things
adult toys the adult happy meals that
just came out yeah why are they selling
for 300 because I guess there's like
rare ones that I guess that one maybe
was her hard to get or something I don't
know that's worth three hundred thousand
dollars it says some of them are selling
for upwards of 300 nobody's buying
somebody's trying to sell them for 300
it has to be the way that has to be what
it's like when you go on eBay and you
see just like something that's worth
eight dollars and somebody's selling it
for like five thousand dollars hoping
that like some like some like Chic but
it needs it that day or something are
these no objects I don't know but I
never went and got anything it's Chic
priced yeah yeah I'll give you Chic
pricing on that show yeah yeah I never
went and got any of these uh I should
have but I didn't uh because why do they
all have what are they all drop acid
I don't get the double eyes I didn't
like the art style of the toys which is
why I didn't I actually like that a
little bit it's a little it's not I get
it it's not McDonald's to me it doesn't
say fun but why is that an adult toy is
it does it vibrate no it's just one yeah
they just did adult I don't know I don't
know I got it honestly what is an adult
Happy Meal does anyone it's just a big
box that is a full-size meal in it and
one of those toys that's why I didn't go
get these because the ba nothing about
it was fun it just looked like I thought
it was gonna be like in cardboard I
totally doesn't have like wine in it or
something yeah anyway all right I love
McDonald's we've discussed see there
they are it's just a box and it's like I
don't know it's not that do you guys
want to go get adult Happy Meals after
this I can't because yes I do okay you
know
um
we I love McDonald's he finds a way to
bring it up in every episode so Filet O
Fish I'm not kidding to be the worst
item in all of fast food
it is it has no place not just on their
menu it is no place in fast food it has
no place in fast food nobody wants the
the so all right let's start the battle
ready so Sal's going to moderate
fish sometimes I like it sometimes I
don't I I think in the the idea of the
filet of fish I think is
okay
sometimes though you'd look at it and be
like that's not good but I will tell you
without the tartar sauce I'll eat that
it's like a fish stick I grew up on fish
sticks yeah yeah and I I the idea of a
fish stick sounds gross but I ate them
and I like them and the idea of that
sounds gross but you throw a slice of
American cheese on it and it's a fish
stick I gotta be in the mood for the
tartar sauce take out the tartar sauce
I'm a fan put it on I'm not so I can go
both ways so what I'm gonna do here is
I'm gonna moderate all right let's start
to battle ready yes
b-a-t-t-l-e buds no chance today between
me and you because this is between me
and Tom okay Tom yeah I gotta say
everything Sal just said I disagree with
the only way I would conceivably like
this is on a bun with tartar sauce
without the cheese
fish head and cheese have no business
ever going together in my opinion shrimp
farm
oh disgusting I find it disgusting okay
I love shrimp and I love parm shrimp
parm I think it's disgusting I think
fish tacos are great but fish choco
should never have cheese on them ever
ever ever ever ever
um
this sandwich and here's what really
pisses me off about this sandwich the
fact that this thing gets a pass when
everybody is crucifying the McNugget for
not being real chicken and nobody ever
mentions this kind of the radar though
that's what's cool about it there is not
a piece sufficient that thing if there's
a piece of chicken in Alaskan pollock
and you know it
is I think it is n't it it is Alaskan
but it's not it's not as processed as
the McNugget you're saying
um I don't care about the McNugget I
care about the filet of fish right I'm
not here to talk about McNuggets go
ahead go ahead bring it down first of
all
the filet of fish do not do not uh honor
Christ
it's there it started
for Lent
it did that's they needed a non-meat
thing on Fridays is that is that Wiley
known why do you guys know it
oh okay yeah
you guys like yes yes oh wow I love that
Tom comes on with real knowledge let me
tell you something I'm glad you brought
that up because it sparked a memory that
I haven't thought of in a long time when
I was I went to Catholic school for 12
years okay in the high school years I
could go find my own meat on Friday if I
needed to during Lent but when I was at
the very trouble
Joe's out on patrol trying to find his
own hand on Friday
that's one way to word it yeah but when
I was a kid and I was at the mercy of my
parents and I they were that was where I
got my meals
my mom
there were Fridays during Lent when my
mom said I'm not going to cook what do
you want and I'd say I get excited like
she was going to let us break and I'd
say what about McDonald's and she'd go
you can get McDonald's if you get a
filet of fish and I'd say never mind
move on my favorite thing in the world I
was like I I don't insult me as a child
with this sandwich I have a child you
passed on I'll take Pizza thank you or
whatever fish sticks uh my mom would
serve them once in a while when she was
like I'm not cooking a big meal tonight
we're gonna have fish sticks and I would
be furious now if you
put it
I hate it I hated them now we've talked
about it on the show before and I've
gotten a weird craving once in a while
for fish sticks but I would have to
douse them in cocktail sauce okay but
but I would never waste a cat Tom yeah I
don't know how often you you know you
hit up a McDonald's in this these days
and ages maybe yeah but you would say
that the filet of fish is something that
you genuinely
it's your favorite thing on the map oh
it is also you so when you go there yeah
it's like I'm getting that number six
okay okay oh wow it's still included in
the meals oh yeah wow you get this every
time oh yeah wow
it's the best so you you you this you
don't want anything else on the menu
like over this enough to yeah look I
don't eat meat so it's I eat fish okay
it's just that gives you fast food is
available to me with that
the Burger King fish sandwich is wet and
it's gross what do they call that fish
sandwich
K fish and it's just got this crummy
iceberg lettuce all over it and it
doesn't it's too big for the Buns Burger
King if you're listening and we know
that you are yeah take notes same to me
people will people will not get
sushi on a Sunday because it's been
sitting there since Friday people will
not get Seafood in a landlocked state
but people will trust these fast food
Outlets to handle this isn't trying to
be something it's not my friends
get an entree at a restaurant in a non
in a landlocked state you might say all
right this is going to be old fish this
we know what this is this is this is
what it is this is not I'm not ordering
sushi at McDonald's right I'm not
ordering a raw filet of fish right and
trusting that it's fresh right that
thing's Frozen they drop it in the fryer
just like they drop everything else for
you it's so unbelievable I gotta be
honest you know I always say like I
don't know if I've ever ordered one
maybe I have but I had had them so I
don't I don't remember how and what
circumstances I suppose I ordered one
maybe there was a place where I went
with there was all different McDonald's
I know I had it but I will say it has
stood the test of time like if that
wasn't selling it wouldn't be on the
menu ditch it of course yeah of course
they're going to have their one fish
sandwich uh so the protesters don't come
after them or whatever you know just
like McDonald's keep salads on the menu
I would say this is the most polarizing
thing on that menu and I will say that
initially I I told Tom before we started
I wish you luck because I do think most
people will say no to the Philippi but
now that I'm thinking it's still on the
menu that means it has it's people that
love it that get it all the time and so
you never know this might be like
something where it's a dark horse where
like every part I say this all the time
but McDonald's you go to McDonald's for
the hits you don't get cute with
McDonald's I was gonna drive through
McDonald's once and I ordered a quarter
pounder with cheese and I remember this
I remember this thing was yesterday the
lady goes would you like bacon on that
and I go no because it was so crazy to
me yeah
that's how you responded to this service
worker I was like well I didn't I was
like what are you talking about
so this to me so you'll get hold on
you're okay
any tattoo you want there's only forever
but you won't get bacon on a burger
which the whole experience will be over
in three hours have you seen bacon at
McDonald's
it comes in disc form okay now it
doesn't yes I get on the breakfast
sandwiches mini strips they used to when
they first started doing it it was in
disc form so it covered the burger but
they still cut it from the same thing
I'm sure yeah it does yeah
my point is this you like the Egg
McMuffin yeah well that's okay yeah just
shake meat on that thing yeah but that's
a piece of ham oh okay
have you ever seen a disc of bacon
where's ham come from I know but have
you ever seen a disc of bacon you've
seen a piece of ham and it's theoretic
oh I could get a disc out of that bacon
you've seen strips have you ever seen a
circle you realize that none of these
shapes are natural right right they're
just all their choices there it is these
are just choices my point is with this
is the fish is square my point is with
the full yes my point is with the filet
of fish it's everything that McDonald's
isn't there is not tartar sauce on one
other thing under that roof there is not
fish in one other thing under that roof
that
name a thing that American cheese I love
Americans too name a thing that it
doesn't enhance I don't care it's gonna
enhanced fish it makes it it makes fish
gross it like it doesn't like fish
though it's fried fried look I know it
just doesn't fish and cheese just don't
go together for me they never have ever
but a fried chicken and cheese would
even fried chicken and cheese uh it's
it's it's it's Hit or Miss for me the
only time I like cheese with fish is I
like if I get a tuna Hoagie I do like
provolone on it okay but that's
different yeah let me let me allow me
Tom thank you
you're okay with putting tuna I mean at
least that's frozen and Flash rot
tuna salad right tuna salad could have
been you open you pop open a can of tuna
you're taking fish that was caught up to
eight years ago and then you're
spreading mayonnaise on it right and you
and you're okay throwing a slice of
cheese on that man that's one of the
riskiest depending The Thundermans
everything exactly depending the style
of the sandwich not every tuna sandwich
a regular tuna sandwich no cheese on it
I wouldn't like tuna an anomaly because
I love a great fresh nice tuna salad
sandwich yeah but if you just think
about what you're doing you're popping
open a can of a fish that died two
presidential administrations ago and
then you're smearing mayonnaise on it
and eating it it's up there with liver
it's up there with liverwurst it's a
wild food I get that and how is that
okay
you look at a tuna can it's like a 10
year it's like a 10-year expiration date
I understand I listen I'm not saying
that the the the what the filet of
fishes freaks me out I eat where I eat
the McDonald's hamburgers and nuggets
for Christ's sakes those are far worse
my point is is or maybe I don't know I
actually want to do a a a ingredient a
health comparison whatever oh look at
that nutrition chart comparison but this
to me is just gross why do you think the
Filet-O-Fish nuggets were a huge fail
because can you read that joke I can't
see it a fish I'm telling you it's there
because it doesn't go bad that is on the
menu to serve a purpose hey we ticked
the box for you guys you can't yell at
us for not having a fish sandwich we got
one here it is and it never goes bad so
it doesn't cost us anything
you know what I mean that's my take on
it let me just say do you like a tuna
melt no okay I do you like it personally
no I like a tuna melt you like a tuna
yeah I love it I don't have it enough so
you just like tuna with cold cheese on
it I like a cold tuna fish salad I don't
care for tuna tuna casserole to me is a
disgrace I mean you go to a classic New
York diner and you get yourself a tuna
melt a little pickle on the side fries
fries steak fries a Diet Coke like a
vintage New York sandwich you're taking
the I I hate hot mayonnaise
yeah like Manny sometimes on a burger
works but like hot hate it like hot
mayonnaise like it was heated up how hot
is it
I don't think cheese on the tuna you're
not eating it off the grill but it's
putting it on a plate and bring it over
to you it's cool down a little bit yeah
but you're you're heating up tuna salad
it's hot it's hot it was hot you don't
want a cold tuna melt right that's gross
right that's not gross either no that's
fine no no but I'm saying though the
idea of a tuna melt is it's hot it might
be going the wrong places yeah they do
it right yeah the balance is is all
there I gotta be honest I want one I
want one right now too I really do
amazing So when you buy if you bit into
a if you bit into a filet of fish as
it's intended right now if I put it in
front of you bit into it you would
recoil
I wouldn't recoil very few things will
make me gag but my point is is what are
some of them it is a pointless in my
opinion it is a pointless item there is
no if you want fish and fast food take
your ass over to Long John Silver's okay
to the most accessible restaurant in the
world I just think it's a [ __ ] sandwich
I think I've tasted it I think it tastes
like every frozen fish Patty you buy in
the supermarket in that bag and those
are gross they take your ass over to a
lot like the existence on the menu is
just enough to do it should not exist
like it's it like you get that out of my
eye line yeah this this this upsets me
yeah you think you're going in it you
think you're better than the filet fish
100 I am better and I find his opinion
suspect because you just said you don't
need any meat yeah well I've eaten
plenty so I can talk about up and down
that McDonald's menu I just currently
don't how what's currently I haven't
eaten me in like 20 years so I ate more
McDonald's than you could ever dream
we would go to lunch at McDonald's in
school yeah we could cross the street
eat McDonald's oh wow
more than you could ever dream of eating
you could go three times a day you
wouldn't catch up
I'm talking big [ __ ]
McDonald's has come in now and now let
me say you're talking crazy big [ __ ]
right I want to say to you yeah did you
or did you not say the McDonald's is a
concierge style experience
that you took out of context in the way
I meant it okay well what does it go on
a joke
concierge you asked for can you do this
can you do that if McDonald's is a
concierge experience
no cheese on that please
that's harder sauce on it please I'd
like a flavor fish with no tartar sauce
of course then Sal can eat one all to
live long day and then we're right back
to square one go buy a bag of these
Frozen [ __ ] things at the supermarket
and go home and make it in your oven
catch my own fish while I'm at it you
and I've argued this McDonald's created
you can make chicken fingers at home do
you think they taste like McDonald's
they do not they do not but what I'm
telling you and and look I I see
examples on both sides here but the
filet of fish is what it is meant to be
it is not selling you anything that it
is not you're comparing it to those
other things that's what it is I
understand but you're asking me to make
my argument as to why I hate it and why
I think it's [ __ ] why I hate it is I
think it is the worst thing in all of
any fast food menu item I could think of
with exception of maybe these new fish
sandwiches these other places are
carting out I don't know these new
fangled fishes
Burger King's doing for 40 years no no
they've had a fish it's Burger King's
though is Burger King's the same concept
all right yeah okay because I I couldn't
imagine any fast food places Wendy's
just serving fish in any other way than
that Wendy's just launched a new one I
don't want Wendy's salmon burger Wendy's
whole thing is like ours is actually
real fish it's like who wants that
nobody wants that at Wendy's nobody
wants this at McDonald's don't eat meat
but that doesn't cut so it's okay for
them to to be like ours is real fish and
you're like oh I don't care about that
but now you're like what's the name of
McDonald's
I guarantee there's nothing one piece of
real fish in that thing hold on
no no hold on hold on that's not what I
said what I said was it pisses me off
that this filet of fish sandwich gets a
pass that the McNuggets do not everybody
actually because it's fish it's got a
good heart it's a [ __ ] rotten piece
of fake fish just like those nuggets are
fake [ __ ] fish flies under the radar
okay fake nuggets with great power comes
down Big Fish I think you like that fake
fish because you won't let yourself eat
any of the other glorious things on that
menu I've used more of them than you'll
ever and you've convinced yourself that
this is good you're saying that this is
Tom's only a McDonald's outlet and so he
has to exercise it and so by when by
virtue of that it's it's at the topic
when you watch an alkie drinking a
non-alcoholic gift and say they enjoy it
when you did eat everything how often
was the filet of fish in your rotation
in the rotation there it is so it was so
it's been it was in the rotation that's
a politician sidestepping answer that is
not what you asked it is that wasn't in
the rotation how often okay was it in
the rotation okay it was one of my three
favorites three favorites yeah so every
third time you're at McDonald's which
was seven days a week per your claim I
would take those every third day like
Jesus you took a fully sure
Tom had the idea of a Supersize Me 30
years ago all right yeah
all right I regularly ate the filet fish
sandwich when everything on the menu was
available to me I have denounced a filet
efficient enough I want you to tell me
what give me the accolades tell me why
you love it tell me what it starts with
the bun
nothing on the McDonald's menu has a bun
as perfect as the filet official but
does it have its own bun it is a soft
bun it's a cheeseburger they sold those
buns
those cheeseburger buns are steamed too
are they not no okay
the bun is perfect it's a bespoke bun
yes it is okay
and also
you get to fly fish
if you don't want tartar sauce today you
tell them no tartar sauce and they know
what you can do but this isn't no no no
that's got nothing to do with white
right away I like the versatility of the
McDonald's Filet versatility anything at
McDonald's tell me why you like this
apparently you can't tell me why you
want bacon on the thing right now what
am I gonna do tell what am I gonna do
with the drive-through they're honking
at the drive through you remember we we
we brushed past this but the poor lady
that we've had to drive through this is
her experience with Joe hi welcome to
McDonald's
I'll take a Big Mac no problem sir would
you like baking with that
this is what she is again what no no why
would I want that no I just said no
that's all you said here
why would I want that to you okay I just
went no okay I couldn't believe the
question it was crazy wait a minute yeah
you can forget what you can take on or
take off tell me what you said it starts
at the bun you're on the right track
keep going
filet of fish is solid it's a good
fillet of fish this ain't no argument
Tommy let me ask you this time when it's
done right is it I'm sorry it has a
really golden crispy it almost plays
like one of those hash browns which
those are gang buses when it does what's
crispy on the outside but it's actually
on the inside the flavor fish it's it's
consistent and solid and quality it
always is but tell me the flavors that
you like tell me what you're liking
about this thing give me a little of the
grit baby tell me a little of the juice
what is it that you like what is it it's
the combination of the soft bun okay of
course and the crunch of the fish and
the melted cheese and the melted cheese
now now I'm like I'm like starting to be
like you know what it's just a tartar
sauce I have well you know what I do
sell often I'll do this I get a number
six meal comes with the fries go in do
you usually eating in my car
take the bun off yeah take a fry yeah
scrape most of the tartar sauce off just
so you have a little trace of tartar
sauce just enough
and you drop some fries on that thing oh
put the bun back on oh that's nice
that's perfect yeah yeah because then
you're just getting the the the little
push off of the top exactly it's just
you get the hint of Target and then
you're getting those golden you're
getting those fries in there and then if
you are eating your fries and you choose
to maybe dip a fry in the harder sauce
left over it's a little bonus go away
right away okay yeah all right I'd like
you to direct some of this that that
made me want way too much eye contact
that made me that made me want that made
me want one I got it in his soothing
voice the way he described it it sounded
good he does have a way of speaking that
that is very amenable but when I when I
I will stick to this when I I there I
don't care for
anything in fast food that reminds me of
something I could immediately make at
home and out of anything that I could
immediately make at home well hold on
let me let me just say I don't and then
you can say hold on Tom this is a space
where you can yell at him yeah
But but so my point is nothing tops the
filet of fish in that department it is
I'll go get a potato roll
um I'll I'll bake one of these things
[Laughter]
there's nothing special about this
McDonald's I want we put a fish sauce
but what's special about a standard
cheeseburger I know they have their own
taste I get that but the McNugget but
you know what you said before you said
you have an issue
um he said you have an issue with a fake
fish but not the fake chicken no no I
don't have an issue with the fake food
no no that's what he's saying right
right oh no you have an issue no no I
said guys I said my issue is is that
this fishing
but I don't think it I don't like that
it doesn't get called out who's calling
out McNuggets there's an article every
other goddamn week am I gonna speak to
this and the pink slime
fish is essentially a fish stick Patty
yes and and and it that's what it is
it's not like that's not a real fish
stick Patty it is what it is they're
saying it's chicken and you can make
tenders like the Burger King tenders are
not like the prod like they claim not to
be like that so you can make chicken
fingers at home or chicken tenders what
do you want to call them McDonald's
can't get couldn't get my phone number
I'll tell you that right now I'll tell
you that right you get what I'm saying
it's like my point is just so then maybe
this is what it is for me like I said on
Fridays in Lent when my mom didn't feel
like cooking we got fish sticks or we
got fish patties and that [ __ ] thing
reminds me of those awful fish sticks
well it sounds like you have an issue
with your mother not McDonald's
sandwich this is childhood trauma
it's not your fault it's not your fault
it's not your fault it's not your fault
stay with us it's not your fault
no I'm saying though it's just my point
is you can't you're not gonna see a
video of them going look at the pink
sludge in the filet of fish but you will
with the McNuggets so why wouldn't they
say the McNuggets pink sludge the filet
of fish doesn't also the power comes
great responsibility the McNugget is the
big swing and D on this on the on the
board here right okay so this is under
the radar Forever This is hip it's cool
you know take it if you want it and also
by the way big big [ __ ] win a good
time I'm sorry you've got
I'm gonna put this to you the filet of
fish I'd like you to put that hand down
I'd like you to keep the hand down while
you address
[Laughter]
the filet of fish yeah yeah is look at
the choke
again a lot of trauma going on here this
is a joke to you
the other one was like
I'll eat the I'll eat the flavor I'll
eat the fish sticks mom don't choke me
all right guys
the filet of fish in the McDonald's
Universe yes wrap your head around this
the filet of fish is the Pixies
of McDonald's
but it reaches its people it has its fan
base and it makes them happy I'm gonna
give you this you've got your Burgers
you that's the eagle you got your
Burgers your Eagles I'll give you this
it's chicken McNuggets the filet fish is
the pavement of McDonald's how it's not
pit and picks these numbers it's not
hitting picks these numbers can I say
I'm I'm moderating this and I know that
I'm skewing a lot this way but I think
it's because he's making
genuinely good points and I would love
to also because your your key Point
seems to be go home and make your own
filet of fish no that's not my key point
listen to what I'm saying I've heard
what you're saying I don't think you
have though
trust me you heard me but I don't think
you're listening I am not saying so go
home and make a filet of fish I'm saying
the reason that McDonald's to me is the
Pinnacle of fast food is because they
create a product that is you cannot
replicate period And the fact that they
have something on the menu that I could
replicate in my opinion I defy you or
replicate that underwhelmed with it you
can't replicate that you think you can
you can I bet you I could come pretty
down I bet you I could come pretty close
to doing a quarter pounder no no you
couldn't oh I could baby I've tried you
can't do it well you can do and what I
can do are two very different things I
would like you to come back I want to do
a special episode about a thing or two
and what you don't know can fill up a
book that's the Robert De Niro and the
boys boys life I wanna I wanna and
Robert De Niro in A Bronx Tale
there's nothing sadder than a wasted
whatever listen
I want I want you to come back for a
special episode of taste buds where we
get a quarter pounder with cheese and a
filet of fish I have to replicate the
filet of fish you have to replicate the
quarter pounder and I promise you my
filet of fish we got the kitchen right
here
we've actually we have a kitchen here
absolutely blow you out of the water
you're saying you'll blow me out of the
water 100 you're saying you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
I'll tell you what else I would like to
pick betting odds I would like to take
betting odds from the listeners and Us
in here like that this could be a thing
this could be a special this could be a
special I am dead serious listeners you
heard it here we want to do what do you
think of this and give us your thoughts
we want to do an episode where Tom
sharpling from the best show comes back
and he is tasked with replicating a
quarter pounder while I am testing
replicating a filet of fish and we vote
on who comes closer with a taste buds
paddle of taste and judges of Sal pick a
breath take a breath
it's not were you filibustering here
you can take a breath everybody's
friends we're all friends I'm not gonna
grab you you're safe mom's not coming
after you today it's okay this is this
is the show yeah so so I I really want
to do that I think yeah I'll do it yeah
I mean yes he's he's on the East Coast
like once every four years but we could
do it we're gonna be four years of
practice yeah what if we flew time out
to do it oh I would do that in a hobby
yeah okay all right that's up but does
Tom want to fly across the country two
bacon fishing which I do not know oh
this snap over here uh well maybe we do
a taste buds in Cali at some point who
knows on our location yeah on location
Oh I thought you were doing a joint
motion on location it was like maybe and
then you would even have the home court
it's a sin that we all can't just go to
McDonald's right now because we have to
film another episode I want us all to
get in the car and go to McDonald's
right now I gotta admit I would I am
open to giving the filet of fish another
chance because at this point because the
Kings they're the McDonald's you are
king that's it period that's it exactly
so if you believe McDonald's Kings why
are you not trusting the king
even the king can do a questionable
thing
anything else what else do you consider
questions it doesn't mean I want him to
cut my Jester's head off you see what
I'm saying the king can do things I
don't agree with a king can be
benevolent truly have no idea
I thought it was about a fish sandwich
at one point no one has any idea what
you're talking about the king can
blestow many great things but he could
also conquer and pillage and I don't you
know there are things a king can do that
I don't care for well fish is that thing
is there anything else on the on the
McDonald's menu that falls into the
filet is that the only the loan item
that the king got wrong or is there
anything else he did wrong I got one for
you guys I want to know what you think
of the pineapple burger that failed the
flail fish was was in competition with
the pineapple Burger in one wow the
filet of fish come out 65 so that I was
going to say pineapple Burger says very
sounds very 60s 70s to me uh look I'd
rather see the filet of fish it was a
slice of pineapple and cheese on a bun
okay oh was it the meat I was a
pineapple pimp I'm glad you brought that
up and I think it supports my argument
you know why the pineapple Burger failed
because nobody bought it there was no
Burger it sat there the goddamn
pineapple went bad and they go we're
losing money here this is stupid what's
a thing we could put in its place that
we won't lose any money on Wow
a frozen [ __ ] fish no it could sit there
until the end of time
the filet of fish and the hula Burger
were in a direct competition to see
which one made the menu the filet of
fish blew the hula Burger off special
facts also what are we talking about
here who and who else
I thought it was with the hula Burger
Ray Kroc did not want the fish sandwich
he had to admit the fish sandwich
belonged on the menu don't you dare wow
and there that even backs me even more
the great Ray Kroc even knew this
sandwich the great Ray Kroc had to say
this sandwich belongs on the menu
against his better judgment yeah right
but he admitted he admitted fault Ray
crosson
never mind the failed pineapple
experiment of 65. what about the menu
right now is there sorry birth control
is there any uh is there any is there
any uh anything on the menu right now
that like that you liken to the fish
that the king got wrong there are past
items that are gone which I'm glad
they're gone they had quinoa bowls at
one point I'm glad they went the way the
dodo uh but no not that I can think of
dodo bird sandwich was good when they
had it too yeah I can't think of
anything on the current men these are
all past disasters though I don't want
to talk about passenger but but it's a
past disaster though I'm saying current
menu right now what's on the current
menu right now I don't think there's
anything on there that I'm like
you know like I don't know I I even I
was making fun of it earlier I'll even
get a salad once a while when I go to
McDonald's I get it without truly
troubling
when you can go to any grocery store and
buy a pre-made bag of salad why are you
not taking your own advice because the
McDonald's salad has things on it that I
can't get at the grocery store like what
have you seen a version of chicken
whatever it is
have you seen what have you seen at the
grocery store all of the pre-made salads
you buy the bag you take it home you
tear it open you pour it in the bag
there's your salad take your own advice
Joe yeah yeah listen the filet of fish
sucks though it doesn't matter but you
did say you you don't like anything that
you can make at home very easily yeah I
didn't say I don't like any I said what
I don't what I like about McDonald's is
they do a thing that you can't do
anywhere else and why I think the fillet
of fish is a problem is because it's a
thing that I feel I could easily
recreate but on top of that far beyond
that that's just one of my points
I'll assume you you would never order in
your
ever order a hot fudge sundae at
McDonald's then you'll never order
because you could do that at home uh how
the hell am I doing a hot fudge sundae
at home you're getting ice cream
I think you'd start yeah I would say
that's the beginning and end of it
you're very so you'll never order that
very snippy you'll never get a soda at
McDonald's
doesn't taste the same
the cheeseburger the fries even the
McNuggets there are people out there
that say they will create that there are
people out there that have said to me
and that will say I will only get my
Fountain Coke at McDonald's because it
only it tastes different than everywhere
else people people have to have stuff
yeah there's people 100 in that there's
a lot of people out there saying a lot
of things that are not true I mean look
we could we could get into that was Sam
Roberts for the for the record oh really
on taste buds he'd mentioned that oh wow
oh thank you oh very good okay I
appreciate it somebody's on my side
today I appreciate I'm on the side I'm
just calling as I said team's a little
I said I agree with you I said I don't
think you can recreate a burger fries or
McNuggets that they make him at home
yeah I'm just looking for I'm go I'm
going I'm gravitating toward good point
we can find we can find every little
exception to this rule Tom you could say
well I guess you don't get ketchup on
your burger because you can get ketchup
these are your rules my friend I said
these are not my rules your rules one of
the things you mentioned are a
concoction watch with that finger also
everything you mentioned is not
concoction made by McDonald's McDonald's
is not concoct soda McDonald's does
concoct their sandwiches though this is
crazy talk why is this great McDonald's
concocts this they don't concoct that I
can't get a thing that they can make at
home but I'll get a thing you can make
why do you care what do you mean why do
you care that someone wants a fish
sandwich and can get a fish sandwich
listen I don't care ultimately I don't
care have fun knock yourself out but
you're asking my opinion anybody who
says knock yourself out cares
I am I am let's move past my I
appreciate the things I can't replicate
things I don't like the sandwich I don't
like what it is I don't get it I don't
that's the good more for me now let me
try to drive across the street to Burger
King and get myself a Whopper I'll leave
McDonald's okay Joe Joe do you do you
feel oh no no no there's a lot of brand
loyalty yeah that was that was don't let
me down if McDonald's said to me one day
all we're doing is Flay a fish from now
on I'd say guys I'll take fries and I'll
see you later that's such a false
argument they're never going to say that
well my mom said it to me every Friday
and Dory went all McDonald's had was
Plenty of Fish on Fridays and I said
I'll pass thank you very much um okay
okay
so
we got a wrap do you think that we go to
the phones now we go to the phones do
you think that uh you have this in the
bag or do you think that it could be
close I don't know do you think that do
you think most people agree with you
from the few comments I've already seen
I would say I'm gonna win but Tom has
made some very sound Arguments for the
filet of fish now I'm not sure if
they're sound arguments or if they're
it's just the way you say them with that
creamy voice but you crazy white velvety
velvety thank you thank you
you've got a tartar sauce okay I would
like to reach try the filet fish I would
when I'm not on a diet so I don't Keel
over
but what's up through the woods on this
diet you know what I at the beginning of
this I swear to God could take it or
leave it I like it sometimes sometimes
like and it really has to do tartar
sauce but more so than any time and I
don't know if it's just because
I don't know why but you know how
sometimes we'll be like we finish him
we're like [ __ ] now I want to go eat
that yeah we do that right and sometimes
it hasn't happened a while right now for
some reason I don't know why but I am
like I gotta get a filet of fish I don't
know why
yeah right I'm sure it's gonna be good
um let's go to the phone all right here
we go our first comment right off the
bat in my opinion is the winner Dave
Sarah says filet of fish is the genital
warts of the fast food world
that is very funny what does that mean
uh it's just I don't know that it's just
gross it's up on you it's seasonal
it's the filet fish seasonal no I had
him
it just made me laugh because it's so
gross uh uh okay let's go down uh here's
a list of things people who order filet
of fish also like condoms man saying I
had fish for lunch
oh
follow Curdy J Lawrence
c-u-r-t-y-j-l-a-w-r-e-n-c-e on Twitter
but let's just say Tom I wouldn't say
you like any of those things that's
really funny though
if I wanted to get physically ill I'd
lick a toilet seat oh Jesus Tom here we
oh look I know I knew this was no no I
knew I know you're here you're here I
knew I was going to lose you're here for
the it's fine I got you I'm here to make
points yes and to be with a friend and I
win because I'm worrying about losing
you and I are more like like formidable
well Tom did did touch on a Cornerstone
of the podcast which is like in the end
it's it's about the journey and he could
lose but still have a good time he he
might have even taking that knowing it
might have been a conventional on the
door oh I knew I knew I was coming in
yeah I say all the time I don't care you
do it we all do it in the food yeah yeah
I'm like Rocky I just I just
want a chance I just want to go the
distance you got way less angry than I
thought you're gonna get today I thought
you were gonna get like all like wound
up and what do you think is gonna Smash
the Place up
by the way if you know Tom he got angry
in there at one point yeah that's it
she'll just come in and they really get
into the yelling and stuff but like I
said I've never met you really so but I
thought that he was going to be like you
idiot no Tom stays in the pocket look of
course I love Sal
I respect you
Joe I respect you I respect you too but
I think a love could grow I think a love
is growing too yeah you have a little
I was going to say you have a little
healing to do
you need to face down don't we all yeah
oh we all do yes yeah but the uh you
know what we're not broken ribs we're
bruised ribs yeah we're getting there
broken McRibs McRibs
when you get that feeling you need fish
fillet healing
give us the win here oh Town plug before
we go to the oh uh yeah best show every
Tuesday night the best show.net doing it
live we got good guests coming up next
few weeks yeah honestly if you for some
reason never heard of the best show jump
right into it it's it's the best it
really is mom is awesome uh I'm really
happy you came through buddy uh this is
great thank you for being here and uh
and our selling my plugs are in the
videos at the top uh check out our March
tell March is on sale on both of our
websites uh tour dates are on both of
our websites if you get a chance uh
subscribe on YouTube uh leave a comment
on iTunes follow on Spotify that's the
best way you can help us can I guess a
number on this saved my guess I'm gonna
say
a huge loss I'm going to say 86 14.
whoa I don't think Tom I think I think
that you're you're you're not I think
you're being a little hard on yourself
there that is that would be one of our
most massive have we ever hit 90 no
right I'm sure it's going to be I don't
think we've ever hit 90. so the 80s is
as far as it usually gets in the 80s
there we go
drum roll Humble Pie whoa wow okay
sorry 73 70 30 it's not 70.2 to 2500
there you go that's actually double what
you thought you have that's around what
I would have if I would have guessed I
would have guessed the margin would be
about that so 70 kill me about 30 hell
yeah
um I would have guessed that but I
honestly though you're after hearing
your argument I was like maybe I'm in
trouble here I don't know but then the
comments I was like oh geez I thought
that's a I think that's pretty firm
getting 30 saying Hell Yeah and uh and
honestly I think after they listen to
this pod I think you're gonna flip some
of those people there's gonna be a
little Spike at McDonald's get ready
Tom I still love you I love you too Joe
hey
and I respect you taste buds they come
into the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two Fool's gonna fight but only one food